This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Many of us know what it feels like to be overlooked. The school we would love to study at doesn't love us back. We get passed over for a job or a promotion. When we ask to try our hand at something, we're told no. Now sometimes rejection might be a true reflection of our abilities. We can't run fast enough to make the team or remember all the facts needed to get through medical school.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们许多人都知道被忽视是什么感觉。我们渴望就读的学校并不青睐我们。我们在工作或晋升中被跳过。当我们请求尝试某事时，得到的回答是否定。当然，有时拒绝可能是我们能力的真实反映。我们跑得不够快而无法入选校队，或者记不住医学院所需的所有事实。
There are other times, however, when rejection is not about our limitations, it's that other people see us as limited. Our concerns over how we are judged are often most acute, most charged, when it comes to the topic of intelligence. Most of us don't just want to be smart. We want to be seen as smart. I just remember being taunted and being told things like, oh, you're too stupid to go on the fourth grade, you idiot, that sort of thing. But yeah, it things like, like, oh, you're too stupid to go on the fourth grade. You idiot. Like that, that sort of thing. Um, but yeah, it was really, it was really painful. This week on Hidden Brain, many of us have knee jaw conclusions about what intelligence
然而，还有其他时候，拒绝并非因为我们的局限，而是因为别人认为我们能力有限。当我们谈论智力这一话题时，我们对他人如何评判我们的担忧往往最为强烈、最为敏感。我们大多数人不仅想变得聪明，还想被视为聪明。我只记得被人嘲笑，被告知诸如“哦，你太笨了，上不了四年级，你这个白痴”之类的话。是的，就是那种话。嗯，但这真的很痛苦。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们许多人对智力是什么以及如何衡量智力有着膝跳反应式的结论。
is and how it can be measured. We think we know what intelligence is. But do we really? It almost instantly seduced me into loving the science of IQ intelligence and I forgot that I was supposed to be on this vendetta. I forgot. In the first three years of his life, Scott Barry Kaufman suffered from a number of ear infections.
我们以为自己了解什么是智力。但我们真的了解吗？它几乎立刻就让我沉迷于智商科学，我忘记了自己本应带着复仇的心态而来。我忘记了。在生命的前三年里，斯科特·巴里·考夫曼患上了多次耳部感染。
It made it very hard for me to process auditory input in real time. And so I was a couple milliseconds behind everyone else. I would hear things and then I would have to, in my head, cognitively process it. Like listen to it over again while everyone else was already onto the next thing. The conclusion that many people drew? Scott wasn't very bright. You know, it's very easy to look at someone and just judge them as dumb because they're slower than someone else. And that sort of processing speed issue is one that I confronted first and foremost as a kid.
这让我很难实时处理听觉输入。所以我比别人慢了几毫秒。我会听到一些东西，然后在脑海中进行认知处理。就像把它重听一遍，而其他人已经进行到下一件事了。许多人得出的结论是什么？斯科特不太聪明。你知道，看着某人并仅仅因为他们比别人慢就判定他们愚蠢是非常容易的。而那种处理速度的问题，是我小时候首当其冲面对的问题。
Scott's teachers didn't know what to make of it. He was often very creative, but he didn't seem to be able to keep up with his peers. Things came to a head in the third grade. And I believe the official diagnosis was I was too immature to go on to fourth grade, and I remember thinking to myself, my gosh, I must be really immature if I'm too immature to go to fourth grade. That's really bad. Scott has seen the reports his teachers wrote about him when he was a kid.
斯科特的老师们不知道该怎么处理这种情况。他通常很有创造力，但似乎无法跟上同龄人的步伐。事情在三年级时达到了顶峰。我相信官方的诊断是我太不成熟，无法升入四年级，我记得当时心想，天哪，如果我太不成熟而无法上四年级，那我一定真的很不成熟。这太糟糕了。斯科特看过他小时候老师为他写的报告。
They say the problem was about more than academics. They say things like he's off to the side, often socially isolated. He seems to be in his own world. I guess they've viewed all that as some form of worrying disability. That I was off on my own planet over there. He quickly discovered that when you repeat a grade, the kids around you start to look at you differently. It really amplified this feeling I already had of
他们说问题不仅仅在于学业。他们说诸如“他总是待在一边，经常在社交上孤立自己。他似乎活在自己的世界里”之类的话。我想他们把这一切都视为某种令人担忧的残疾。认为我当时在自己的星球上。他很快发现，当你留级时，周围的孩子开始以不同的眼光看你。这确实放大了我内心深处的一种感觉：
that I was different. I remember even, you know, from first to third grade, I felt like a huge outsider from the other kids, but then making me repeat third grade and then having all my friends go on and they kept me there, made me like it amplified it to a very, very large degree. I remember feeling really, really low self-esteem and I remember just being very, very confused because I didn't actually feel like there was anything wrong with me. Scott has a specific memory from that additional year he spent in third grade. A group of kids formed a circle around him in the bathroom.
我与众不同。我记得甚至从一年级到三年级，我就觉得自己在其他孩子中是个彻头彻尾的局外人，但后来让我留级三年级，看着我所有的朋友都升上去了，而他们把我留在那儿，这在很大程度上放大了这种感觉。我记得当时自尊心非常非常低，而且我记得非常非常困惑，因为我实际上并不觉得我有什么问题。斯科特对他在三年级多待的那一年有着一段特别的记忆。一群孩子在洗手间里围住了他。
If you took me back to Penwin Elementary School and you're like, show me the bathroom, show me the sink that your face was pushed into the sink and the water was running, I could point you directly to it. And I just remember being taunted and being told things like, oh, you're too stupid to go on the fourth grade. You idiot. That's that sort of thing. But yeah, it was really painful. When Scott was seven and again at 11, school administrators made him take IQ tests so they could figure out next steps for him. One test stands out in his memory like a scene from a movie. I remember driving up this very windy road to get there somehow seems fitting.
如果你带我回到彭温小学，说“带我去洗手间，指给我看你的脸被按进哪个水槽，水还在流”，我可以准确地指出来。我只记得被人嘲笑，被告知诸如“哦，你太笨了，上不了四年级，你这个白痴”之类的话。就是那种话。但那真的很痛苦。当斯科特七岁和十一岁时，学校管理人员让他参加智商测试，以便他们能为他找出后续步骤。一次测试在他的记忆中像电影场景一样突出。我记得开车走在这条非常蜿蜒的路上，去那里似乎很合适。
Very, very long, long windy road. I remember the road I remember I was with my mom remember the building. So as I'm there and I'm taking this like cute testing session, I remember second guessing all my answers. I remember desperately wanting to show him I was smart. And that report, his observations are things like, Scott obviously wanted to do well and he, he second guess his choice a lot. My estimation is that he is very, very bright but gets in his own way because of his self-doubt. All I knew from that meeting is that I was shipped off to a whole school for kids with
非常非常长、蜿蜒曲折的路。我记得那条路，我记得我和我妈妈在一起，记得那栋建筑。所以当我在那里参加这个智商测试时，我记得对自己所有的答案都产生了怀疑。我记得非常渴望向他展示我很聪明。而那份报告，他的观察结果是诸如“斯科特显然想表现好，他对自己选择的怀疑很多。我的评估是他非常非常聪明，但因为自我怀疑而阻碍了自己”。我从那次会面中知道的全部就是我被送往了一所专门为有学习障碍的孩子开设的学校。
learning disabilities. I was taken away from my public school, so that's all I knew. There was like, I know I took this test, I knew it was a terrifying experience, and then I know I was taken away from my public school, so that's all I knew. I knew I took this test, I knew it was a terrifying experience, and then I knew I was shipped off, taken away from all my friends. So that was pretty traumatic. From the outside, it might seem like Scott was privileged. His family had the resources for him to go to a school that would meet his needs. But as a kid, Scott felt the adults in his life was sending him a clear message. I'm really different.
我被带离了公立学校，这就是我所知道的一切。我知道我参加了这次测试，我知道这是一次可怕的经历，然后我知道我被带走了，被带离了我所有的朋友。所以这相当令人痛苦。从外部看，斯科特似乎很幸运。他的家庭有资源让他去一所能满足他需求的学校。但作为一个孩子，斯科特觉得他生活中的成年人在向他传递一个明确的信息：我真的很不同。
Like I am, oh my, okay, we'll go even further. I'm a freak. Like I'm a freak. Like I am, like something's really wrong with me. The outcome of Scott's IQ test was the opposite of what he had secretly hoped for. His dream was that he would do so well that the psychologist would recommend he moved to a prestigious school near his Philadelphia home. It was called a Havaford school. Now, each day on his way to his new school, he passed Haviford. To Scott, his dream school might as well have been on Mars.
就像我，哦天哪，好吧，我们再深入一点。我是个怪胎。就像我是个怪胎。就像我，就像我真的有什么问题。斯科特智商测试的结果与他暗中希望的恰恰相反。他的梦想是表现得足够好，让心理学家建议他转到费城家附近的一所名校。那所学校叫哈弗福德学校。现在，他每天去新学校的路上都会经过哈弗福德。对斯科特来说，他的梦想学校简直就像在火星上一样。
By the 6th grade, Scott was back in public school, but still on the special ed track. That was the year he discovered that along with kids like him who had special needs, there was another category of kids who were really special. I have a vivid memory of walking to my special ed classroom and hearing the announcement on the speaker. Um, uh, gifted kids report to room three for your gifted classes. I remember thinking of myself, wow, here I am reporting to my special ed class. Like, like, like, what, who are these people? That was one of my first introductions to the term gifted
到了六年级，斯科特回到了公立学校，但仍然在特殊教育轨道上。那一年他发现，除了像他这样有特殊需求的孩子外，还有另一类孩子，他们才是真正的“天才”。我有一个生动的记忆，走去特殊教育教室时，听到扬声器里的广播。嗯，天才儿童请到三号教室上天才班。我记得心想，哇，我在这里去上我的特殊教育课。就像，这些人是谁？顺便说一句，那是我第一次接触“天才”这个词，
by the way, it was through the speaker in my school, in my middle school. And it was a vivid moment for me. It really was a vivid moment, because I was like, wait a minute, wait a minute. There's a whole different class of humans. That's the direct opposite of what I am, and they're the gifted ones. And suddenly, it was like a, I'm stuck in the complete opposite world. It felt awful. One way it felt awful was that the expectation carried me around from class to class to class,
是通过我中学的扬声器。那对我来说是一个生动的时刻。确实是一个生动的时刻，因为我当时想，等一下，等一下。还有一类完全不同的人类。那和我完全相反，他们是天才。突然间，感觉就像我被困在一个完全相反的世界里。感觉糟透了。感觉糟透的一种方式是，这种期望伴随着我从一个教室到另一个教室，
even some of the more mainstream classes I was starting to be put into in middle school. I remember being in a mainstream class and on the first day of class I saw this girl who I had such a crush on. Oh my gosh, I was way too shy to ever say anything to her, but I saw her all around. And she was at the front of the classroom. And I was walking in and I think I sat at the back and the teacher opened up the class and said,
甚至包括我在中学开始被安排进入的一些主流课程。我记得在一门主流课上，第一天我就看到了这个我非常迷恋的女孩。天哪，我太害羞了，从来不敢对她说什么，但我到处都能看到她。她坐在教室的前面。我走进去，我想我坐在了后面，老师打开课说，
is Scott Kaufman here? I was like, oh my gosh, like looking down, you know, Scott Kaufman here, oh you're Scott Kaufman. Can you please come up to the front of the class? Your mom says that you need, you have trouble listening to hearing things and that it really help you hear when I'm my directions in the classroom.
斯科特·考夫曼在这里吗？我当时想，哦天哪，低着头，你知道，斯科特·考夫曼在这里，哦你是斯科特·考夫曼。你能请到教室前面来吗？你妈妈说你需要，你在听力方面有困难，这真的能帮助你在教室里听到我的指示。
She sat me right next to this girl that I had a crush on. And I mean, that was more to fight. Can you imagine, everyone listening to this episode right now, think back to your 12 year old self and that happening. I mean, I was so mortified. And everyone listening to this episode right now, think back to your 12 year old self. And that happened. I mean, I was so mortified. There were more psychological tests as time passed.
她把我安排坐在那个我暗恋的女孩旁边。我的意思是，那简直是折磨。你能想象吗，现在听这一集的每个人，回想一下你12岁的时候发生了那种事。我的意思是，我太尴尬了。现在听这一集的每个人，回想一下你12岁的时候。发生了那种事。我的意思是，我太尴尬了。随着时间的推移，还有更多的心理测试。
Scott found himself simultaneously angry with psychologists and fascinated by them. On one occasion, his mother took him to see a therapist. I remember he was asking me what I want to be someday. What are my dreams? I remember seeing the tag named Dr. Milneck, I believe was named Dr. Psychologist. And I remember it snapped at my head, I remember telling him I want to be a psychologist.
斯科特发现自己既对心理学家感到愤怒，又对他们着迷。有一次，他母亲带他去看治疗师。我记得他问我将来想成为什么样的人。我的梦想是什么？我记得看到那个标签写着米尔内克博士，我相信是叫米尔内克博士。我记得它在我脑海中闪过，我记得告诉他我想成为一名心理学家。
I want to be a psychologist and be, and I still have the reports I have them all saved from like 1989 or something like that where it said, when he grows up, he wants to be an academic PhD psychologist. But here's a big kicker to this. My mom tells me that they told her that your son wants to be an academic PhD psychology, wrote that on his thing, but we think he has delusions of grandeur. In Scotts Young Mind, psychologists had all this power. They were able to peer into your head and see things no one else could see.
我想成为一名心理学家，而且我仍然保存着那些报告，我把它们都存着，从1989年左右开始，上面写着：当他长大后，他想成为一名学术博士心理学家。但这里有一个很大的转折。我妈妈告诉我，他们告诉她，你的儿子想成为一名学术博士心理学家，在报告上写了那个，但我们认为他有夸大妄想。在斯科特年轻的心中，心理学家拥有所有的权力。他们能够窥视你的大脑，看到别人看不到的东西。
When they said stuff, people listened to them. The things they wrote down in their charts changed your life. They determined which school you went to, and which school you didn't go to. Scott felt psychology had shaped his life for the worse. If he could become a psychologist himself, he was sure he could do better. Sometimes he'd imagine himself giving talks about psychology to wrapped audiences. I remember taking a shower and just closing my eyes and giving a 50-minute speech on human potential.
当他们说些什么时，人们会听他们的。他们在图表上写下的东西改变了你的生活。他们决定了你去哪所学校，不去哪所学校。斯科特觉得心理学让他的生活变得更糟。如果他能自己成为一名心理学家，他确信自己能做得更好。有时他会想象自己向全神贯注的听众发表关于心理学的演讲。我记得洗澡时闭上眼睛，发表了一场50分钟关于人类潜能的演讲。
The thing that excited me were ideas about how people are capable of so much more than they realize, how we don't really see the fullness of a human being. And this is even before Ted Talks, but I remember in my head, the recollection of it is that the kind of talk I was giving is matches exactly like what a modern day Ted Talk looks like, you know. Scott tried to become his own psychologist. If he couldn't convince psychologists that he had potential, he decided he would prove his case to himself. I became obsessed with IQ tests around that point. I remember just taking one IQ test after another, some of them I didn't do too well on and
让我兴奋的是关于人们如何比他们意识到的更有能力，我们如何并没有真正看到一个人的全部。这甚至是在TED演讲之前，但我记得在我的脑海中，对它的回忆是，我所做的演讲类型与现代TED演讲的样子完全吻合，你知道。斯科特试图成为自己的心理学家。如果他不能说服心理学家他有潜力，他决定向自己证明这一点。我在那个时候开始沉迷于智商测试。我记得一个接一个地参加智商测试，其中一些我做得不太好，
then some of them I did really really well on and I was like, okay I'm gonna throw away those ones that said I didn't, they weren't so good. I'm gonna keep dealing with them. I remember even, I remember one IQ test result I took on the internet which said I was like, okay, I'm gonna throw away those ones that said I didn't learn so good. I'm gonna keep dealing with them. I remember even, I remember one IQ test result I took on the internet, which said I was profoundly gifted. And I took it and I printed it out and I put it on my bedroom wall. I put this IQ test result on my bedroom wall. I remember the specific corner of the wall that I put it on, displaying my IQ test results
然后有一些我做得非常好，我就想，好吧，我要扔掉那些说我做得不好的。我要继续处理它们。我甚至记得，我记得我在互联网上参加的一个智商测试结果，上面说我，好吧，我要扔掉那些说我学得不好的。我要继续处理它们。我甚至记得，我记得我在互联网上参加的一个智商测试结果，上面说我非常有天赋。我参加了它，把它打印出来，贴在我的卧室墙上。我把这个智商测试结果贴在我的卧室墙上。我记得我把它贴在墙上的特定角落，展示我的智商测试结果，
I took from the internet. Yeah, I think I was desperate to prove to anyone, like just to show anyone, like, look, there was, there's some intelligence over here. Scott had one of the pivotal interaction with the world of psychology and IQ tests. When he was in high school, he requested access to some of the classes his friends on the gifted track were taking. He was told to go see his school psychologist to get permission. Yeah, I remember the office. It was a tiny room with file cabinets and a desk.
我从互联网上拿到的。是的，我想我当时迫切地想向任何人证明，就像只是想向任何人展示，看，这里有一些智力。斯科特与心理学和智商测试的世界有过一次关键的互动。当他在高中时，他申请进入他那些在天才轨道上的朋友正在上的一些课程。他被告知去见他的学校心理学家以获得许可。是的，我记得那个办公室。那是一个放着文件柜和桌子的小房间。
There's like a little small desk that he sat in and I sat right next to him. And he had my files of like my files. My worst nightmare, by the way, I was like, I really hope he doesn't look at my files and he just looks at who I am now. Scott was now 17 years old. The file on the psychologist's desk was a report with Scott's IQ test. And he's like, so look, here's the deal. And he draws on a piece of paper, it it other napkin or a piece of paper?
有一个小桌子，他坐在那里，我就坐在他旁边。他有我的档案，就像我的档案。顺便说一句，我的噩梦，我当时想，我真的希望他不要看我的档案，只看现在的我是谁。斯科特当时17岁。心理学家桌上的档案是一份关于斯科特智商测试的报告。他说，好吧，听着，事情是这样的。他在一张纸上画，是餐巾纸还是纸？
He drew a bell curve and a bell curve for for anyone that doesn't know what a bell curve is. You can place your someone's IQ score on this kind of bell curve that shows what proportion in the population, what percentage you are, where you are, where you stand, where do you stand on IQ comparative and also the general population or in your particular demographic. And he started in the far right and he had the label gifted there. He's like, this is the far right,
他画了一个钟形曲线，对于任何不知道什么是钟形曲线的人。你可以把某人的智商分数放在这种钟形曲线上，它显示了人口中的比例，你处于什么百分比，你在哪里，你在智商比较以及一般人口或特定人口统计中处于什么位置。他从最右边开始，并在那里贴上了“天才”的标签。他说，这是最右边，
you know, like of the bell curve, about 130. And he starts moving to the left. Oh my God, he moved him to the left, he moves like 110. He's like, well this is about where average is, you know, about the Hunter mark. And he still keeps moving to the left. I feel like I'm getting agitated over here. You know, like, he's, I'm like, when's he gonna stop?
你知道，就像钟形曲线的，大约130。然后他开始向左移动。天哪，他把他移到了左边，他移到了大约110。他说，嗯，这就是平均水平所在的地方，你知道，大约在100的标记处。他仍然继续向左移动。我觉得我在这里变得焦躁不安。你知道，就像，我心想，他什么时候才会停下来？
When's that pen gonna stop? Like, what are we getting at here? He stops to a score which I believe was my score when I was tested at age eight or nine. It wasn't even the one I was tested eleven and he's like you know this is this is your score he's like you're not gifted you can't you know fortunately you can't qualify for gift education but I'm here you know if you want to talk about anything else school psychology related
那支笔什么时候才会停下来？就像，我们在这里要表达什么？他停在一个分数上，我相信那是我八九岁时测试的分数。甚至不是我十一岁时测试的那个，他说，你知道这是你的分数，他说，你不是天才，你不能，你知道幸运的是，你不能获得天才教育的资格，但我在这里，你知道如果你想谈论任何其他与学校心理学相关的事情。
What was your score Scott? 89, something like the 87 something like that. I mean, that's in that's almost in bar I'm almost embarrassed because it's like It's a pretty low score not that anyone should be in barist who has that score But it's I am so resistant to having people judge me through the lens of that. That's why I don't even really tell the story anymore. I feel like I'm even taking a risk, like even saying, giving a number. I'm not that person anymore. When this happens, Scott,
你的分数是多少，斯科特？89，大约87左右。我的意思是，这几乎是，我几乎感到尴尬，因为这就像，这是一个相当低的分数，并不是说任何有那个分数的人都应该感到尴尬。但我非常抵触让人们通过那个镜头来评判我。这就是为什么我甚至不再真正讲这个故事了。我觉得我甚至在冒险，就像甚至说出，给出一个数字。我不再是那个人了。当这种情况发生时，斯科特，
do you recall I'm saying where you sat on the IQ spectrum? I mean, if 130 was gifted and 90 to 110 was normal, did he describe what 87 was? He didn't really describe it to me. No, there wasn't a real explanation. It was really like, you're not gifted. And this is the, so my hands are tied.
你还记得我说过你坐在智商谱系的什么位置吗？我的意思是，如果130是天才，90到110是正常，他描述了87是什么吗？他并没有真正向我描述它。不，没有真正的解释。这真的就像，你不是天才。这就是，所以我的手被束缚了。
Like, what can I do? I understand that after you left his office, you went to the school library and you basically looked up how to read IQ tests. What did you find? I remember seeing a textbook on Intumine Intelligence and they have a chart in there that shows what different IQ bands people are capable of achieving. And I remember seeing my range that he kind of just showed me and it said it said unlikely to graduate high school. And I, you know, I always had this rebellious bone in my body though because I remember
就像，我能做什么？我了解到在你离开他的办公室后，你去了学校图书馆，基本上查阅了如何解读智商测试。你发现了什么？我记得看到一本关于智力测验的教科书，里面有一张图表，显示了人们能够达到的不同智商区间。我记得看到他给我看的那个范围，上面写着“不太可能高中毕业”。而且我，你知道，我身上总有一根叛逆的骨头，因为我记得
saying, that and throwing the book across the library. By this point, Scott was actually doing well in school. He had a case to be moved to the gift attract. But in looking at the results of his IQ test from when he was in elementary school, the school psychologist was saying some important things. First, the test had picked up something innate about Scott. It didn't matter how much he'd learned or what he'd accomplished in the years afterward. The test had peered into his mind and the test had determined he was not gifted.
说，那个，然后把书扔过图书馆。到这个时候，斯科特在学校里其实表现得很好。他有理由被调到天才轨道。但在查看他小学时的智商测试结果时，学校心理学家说了一些重要的话。首先，测试捕捉到了关于斯科特的一些天生的东西。无论他后来几年学到了多少或取得了什么成就，这都不重要。测试已经窥视了他的大脑，测试已经确定他不是天才。
Not then, not now, not ever. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Scott Barry Kaufman desperately wanted to be seen as a smart kid. But everyone kept telling him, he was the opposite of smart. He ended up repeating third grade, was sent to a school for kids with learning differences and scored poorly on IQ tests. Scott didn't just experience these things as setbacks. He found them confusing.
不是那时，不是现在，永远不是。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。斯科特·巴里·考夫曼迫切地想被视为一个聪明的孩子。但每个人都一直告诉他，他与聪明恰恰相反。他最终留级了三年级，被送往一所为有学习差异的孩子开设的学校，并在智商测试中得分很低。斯科特不仅将这些经历视为挫折。他发现它们令人困惑。
He thought of himself as a smart kid with lots of potential. Why didn't the world see him that way? At one point though, when Scott was in high school, a new teacher noticed that he looked bored in the special led resource room. And she was looking at me for most of that class, and I was wondering why she kept looking at me. But she took me aside after class, and she said, look, I just had to ask,
他认为自己是一个有很大潜力的聪明孩子。为什么世界不那样看他呢？不过有一次，当斯科特在高中时，一位新老师注意到他在特殊教育资源室里看起来很无聊。她在大部分课程中都在看着我，我很好奇为什么她一直看着我。但下课后她把我拉到一边，她说，听着，我只是不得不问，
like, what are you doing here? You know, I see you. And, oh boy, it really was like a profound moment in my life. I could remember thinking in my head, what am I doing here? Repeating her question. And then, yeah, what am I doing here? It was just the empowerment I needed. Scott felt like he had been trying for years to tell people he had potential.
就像，你在这里做什么？你知道，我看到了你。而且，天哪，这确实是我生命中深刻的时刻。我记得在脑海中想，我在这里做什么？重复她的问题。然后，是的，我在这里做什么？这正是赋予我力量所需要的。斯科特觉得他多年来一直试图告诉人们他有潜力。
Suddenly, there was someone else who could see the same thing. I felt like people thought I was crazy for thinking that I had some potential. In this moment, I was like, yeah, I don't know what I'm doing here. That's what I've been trying to tell people. Scott was allowed to leave special ed on a trial basis. The effect of someone believing in him was transformative. I actually went from like a CD student to like a straight A student like almost overnight and I took summer school classes. I joined so many things like plays, you know, I did musicals and everything.
突然间，有另一个人能看到同样的东西。我觉得人们认为我疯了，因为我认为自己有一些潜力。在这一刻，我心想，是的，我不知道我在这里做什么。这就是我一直试图告诉人们的。斯科特被允许以试用期的方式离开特殊教育。有人相信他的效果是变革性的。我实际上从一个C/D学生变成了一个全A学生，几乎是一夜之间，我参加了暑期学校课程。我加入了这么多东西，比如戏剧，你知道，我参加了音乐剧和一切。
I just, something just erupted in me at that point where all this stuff just bubbled forth and I was like, I love learning, I love everything about this and thank you for giving me that opportunity finally, school system that never gave me opportunity before. And it's almost like this one, this one teacher in this one moment, it was almost like a light bulb going off in your head, it sounds like. It wasn't like a white bulb, it was like volcano erupting, a volcano of human potential that had been dormant.
我只是，在那一点上，有什么东西在我体内爆发了，所有这些东西都涌现出来，我心想，我热爱学习，我热爱关于这一切的一切，谢谢你终于给了我那个机会，学校系统以前从未给我机会。这几乎就像这位老师在这一刻，听起来就像你脑子里亮起了一盏灯。那不是一盏灯，那就像火山爆发，一座休眠的人类潜能火山。
One day, he was hanging out with friends after school. And they said, hey, we had to just go to the choir room and pick up something. This was after class, after school, after school. And so I just walked with them and they were in the choir room and the choir conductor was there. And I remember just sort of like making fun of them. Like, I was like, you know, you all sound like this. And the choir conductor turned around, looked at me and said, what just happened? Like, you have talent. Like, do you want to join our choir? And so that was one of my first big things that gave me such an amazing sense of efficacy and excitement and it just
有一天，放学后他和朋友们在一起。他们说，嘿，我们得去合唱室拿点东西。这是下课后，放学后，放学后。所以我只是和他们一起走，他们在合唱室里，合唱指挥在那里。我记得只是像取笑他们一样。就像，我心想，你们听起来都像这样。合唱指挥转过身，看着我说，刚才发生了什么？就像，你有天赋。就像，你想加入我们的合唱团吗？所以那是我第一件让我有如此惊人的效能感和兴奋感的大事，它只是
felt so good. I mean I can't tell you how good it feels to go from a long-pure near life where you are invisible. You are literally invisible and you know deep inside you that you're capable of more to a moment where suddenly you're now allowed to be discovered. It was almost like I went through nine grades where I was forbidden for anyone even to see that I had any potential. see that I had any potential. So you graduate high school and you still want to become a psychologist. You decide that you want to go to Carnegie Mellon to college in your home state. It has a strong program in cognitive psychology.
感觉太好了。我的意思是，我无法告诉你，从一个你隐形的长期纯粹的生活中走出来，感觉有多好。你实际上是隐形的，你知道内心深处你有能力做更多的事情，到一个突然间你现在被允许被发现的时刻。这几乎就像我经历了九个年级，我被禁止让任何人看到我有任何潜力。看到我有任何潜力。所以你高中毕业了，你仍然想成为一名心理学家。你决定去卡内基梅隆大学上大学，在你所在的州。它在认知心理学方面有很强的项目。
So you take the SAT, what happens? So I didn't do too hard on the SAT. I'm going to just lay it to you straight there, my friend. Huge anxiety. I'm getting anxiety thinking about that SAT session, even just thinking about it, like, how many are 20 or 25 years later? I'm anxiety.
所以你参加了SAT，发生了什么？所以我SAT考得不太好。我直接告诉你吧，我的朋友。巨大的焦虑。想到那次SAT考试，我甚至感到焦虑，即使只是想到它，就像，20或25年后？我焦虑。
I remember seeing the countdown of the clock on the screen, tick, tick, you got two minutes left to answer all these questions, and my brain just freezing. And I didn't do too hot on the SAT. I'm wondering at the point of which you got your SAT scores back, it seems almost as if this is deja vu. You've taken another test and the test is supposed to purportedly tell you something about your potential and how smart you are and whether you which track you can
我记得看到屏幕上的时钟倒计时，滴答，滴答，你只剩下两分钟来回答所有这些问题，我的大脑就冻结了。我SAT考得不太好。我想知道在你拿到SAT成绩的那一刻，这似乎几乎是似曾相识。你又参加了另一场测试，而这场测试据称要告诉你关于你的潜能以及你有多聪明，以及你是否，你走哪条轨道，
go to, which college you can get into. And very much like what happened when you were eight and what happened when you were 11, you were having a test that basically told you, Scott Barry Kaufman, you were not destined for this track. You are destined for some other track. This is very astute of you to notice that, but that's exactly how I felt as well. I was like, again, you can't escape it. To compensate for his weak score, but also to settle scores with standardized testing, Scott came up with a plan. He decided to apply to the psychology program at Carnegie Mellon University and to focus his application essay on his pet peeve with standardized tests. He argued that these tests did not reveal
你可以进入哪所大学。而且非常像你八岁和十一岁时发生的事情，你参加了一场测试，基本上告诉你，斯科特·巴里·考夫曼，你不注定走这条轨道。你注定走另一条轨道。你能注意到这一点非常敏锐，但这确实也是我的感受。我心想，再一次，你无法逃避它。为了弥补他薄弱的分数，但也为了与标准化测试算账，斯科特想出了一个计划。他决定申请卡内基梅隆大学的心理学项目，并将他的申请论文重点放在他对标准化测试的厌恶上。他认为这些测试并没有揭示
the true potential of students. And I wrote a very, very from the heart personal essay, which I still have saved, saying our notions of human potential are really inaccurate. We need broader notions that go beyond standardized metrics to understand the real achievement potential of humans. And I wrote that from a heart and I got rejected from the Cognitive Science Program at Carnegie Mellon, presumably an orange part to my lower SAT scores.
学生的真实潜能。我写了一篇非常非常发自内心的个人论文，我仍然保存着它，说我们对人类潜能的概念真的很不准确。我们需要超越标准化指标的更广泛的概念，以了解人类真正的成就潜能。我发自内心地写了那篇论文，但我被卡内基梅隆大学的认知科学项目拒绝了，大概部分是因为我较低的SAT分数。
But Scott didn't give up. He came up with a new idea. What if he applied to another department at the same school? Scott's voice teacher in high school thought he could become a professional opera singer. Could he get into Carnegie Mellon via the opera program? And I was like, you know what, I can, let me think stars to them in the in the opera program at Carnegie Mellon. Maybe I can get in that way. Scott's favorite song in high school was stars from Lameez Robb. He sang it all the time, including it a performance in a senior year, a few months before his audition.
但斯科特没有放弃。他想出了一个新主意。如果他申请同一所学校的另一个系呢？斯科特高中的声乐老师认为他可以成为一名专业的歌剧演员。他能通过歌剧项目进入卡内基梅隆大学吗？我心想，你知道吗，我可以，让我考虑一下卡内基梅隆大学歌剧项目的明星们。也许我可以那样进去。斯科特高中时最喜欢的歌是《悲惨世界》里的《星光》。他一直唱这首歌，包括在毕业那年的表演中，就在他试镜前几个月。
I went to the audition and I sang my heart out. Everything in that moment of like frustration, anger, like I put it into that song. And they accepted, they thought they told my parents that, I never saw you. Do you reconnness to me? And they, they thought they told my parents that they thought I was, that I could be a real good opera singer and they accepted me in a partial scholarship to Carnegie Mellon. When the other department at the university and they rejected me, so I didn't bother to tell the music department, just so you you know I've already been rejected in another part of your school. I didn't do that. Scott mentally prepared himself for the path of an opera student. But then his
我去试镜，我全心全意地唱了。那一刻所有的挫折、愤怒，我把它投入到了那首歌里。他们接受了，他们认为，他们告诉我的父母，我从未见过你。你认出我了吗？他们，他们认为，他们告诉我的父母，他们认为我是，我可以成为一名真正优秀的歌剧演员，他们接受了我，并给了我卡内基梅隆大学的部分奖学金。当大学的另一个系拒绝我时，所以我没有费心告诉音乐系，只是为了让你知道我已经在这个学校的另一个部分被拒绝了。我没有那样做。斯科特在心理上为歌剧学生的道路做好了准备。但后来他的
second semester he signed up for an intro to psychology course. It reaffirmed how much I love, like it just, you know, when you meet something, you're like, this is me, and then you go away from it, and you come back to it, and still this is me, that's telling you something. Like that's important information. And I was like, I got to do this. He quietly transferred into the psychology department. Soon he was learning about intelligence and the science of IQ tests. His goal from the very start was to tear down the edifice of IQ testing, but he felt he had to go into the lion's den first in order to tear it down.
第二学期，他报名参加了一门心理学入门课程。它重申了我有多爱，就像它，你知道，当你遇到某事时，你心想，这就是我，然后你离开它，你又回来，它仍然是这就是我，这在告诉你一些事情。就像那是非常重要的信息。我心想，我必须做这个。他悄悄转到了心理学系。很快他就在学习关于智力和智商测试的科学。他从一开始的目标就是拆除智商测试的大厦，但他觉得他必须先进入狮子窝才能拆除它。
By the time he was 20, Scott had talked his way into a spotted Cambridge University in England, working with one of the most prominent researchers on the science of intelligence. I was so nervous and excited. I didn't know if I was going to be able to be as intelligent as I needed to be a research assistant at Cambridge University. It was almost hard for me to fathom that I would legitimately be intelligent enough to be worthy of the situation. I was like, that's even, you know, Scott, even with all your grandiose, fan-seasonary things, this is a little...
到20岁时，斯科特已经通过谈话进入了英国剑桥大学的一个名额，与智力科学领域最杰出的研究人员之一一起工作。我当时非常紧张和兴奋。我不知道我是否能够像我需要的那样聪明，成为剑桥大学的研究助理。我几乎无法想象我真的会聪明到足以配得上这种情况。我心想，那甚至，你知道，斯科特，即使有你所有宏大的、幻想的东西，这也有点……
Are you serious? What are you doing, Scott? What are you doing? But Scott's mentor, Nick McIntosh, said him at ease. Nick couldn't have been more wonderful, more supportive, and he must have seen something in me. He saw the person that I was in that moment. Scott didn't tell Nick about his own experience with IQ tests. He was still ashamed. I mean, he didn't know my background. By the way, I kept all this a secret from him throughout or into all the times who worked together and everything.
你是认真的吗？你在做什么，斯科特？你在做什么？但斯科特的导师尼克·麦金托什让他感到轻松。尼克再好不过了，再支持不过了，他一定在我身上看到了什么。他看到了那一刻的我。斯科特没有告诉尼克他自己关于智商测试的经历。他仍然感到羞耻。我的意思是，他不知道我的背景。顺便说一句，我在我们一起工作的所有时间里都对这件事保密。
You know, he didn't look at my IQs grow when I was age 11. And he, um, he accepted me to work with him. And I did some pretty, uh, pretty rigorous research with him in that six months and as an undergrad that would then form the basis of my master's thesis with him. Starting on the neck, Scott started to learn about the deep history of IQ tests, starting with Alfred Benet, a French psychologist. In 1904, Alfred Benet was charged by the French government with devising a test. The idea was to direct resources to kids who needed help in school. Alfred bin A made it very clear what he thought the test could and could not measure.
你知道，他没有看我11岁时的智商分数。他，嗯，他接受了我与他一起工作。在那六个月里，我与他进行了一些相当严谨的研究，作为本科生，这后来构成了我与他硕士论文的基础。从麦金托什开始，斯科特开始了解智商测试的深厚历史，从法国心理学家阿尔弗雷德·比奈开始。1904年，阿尔弗雷德·比奈被法国政府指派设计一项测试。这个想法是将资源引导给学校里需要帮助的孩子。阿尔弗雷德·比奈非常清楚地表达了他认为该测试能衡量什么和不能衡量什么。
He wrote that. He said, this is not an intelligence test that I'm creating. This is a test that I've been given the task of differentiating those who would need more remediation and those who don't. We say only about the child's current needs, not his future potential. He said this, but he said this in the manual, in the testing the Benei manual, the original way, he says things like that. We do not even begin to report
他写道。他说，我创造的这不是一个智力测试。这是一个测试，我被赋予了区分那些需要更多补救措施的人和那些不需要的人的任务。我们只说孩子当前的需求，而不是他未来的潜能。他说过这个，但他是在手册里说的，在比奈测试手册里，最初的方式，他说诸如此类的话。我们甚至没有开始报告
what this person is capable of. not even begin to report what this person is capable of. The great tragedy of that story is that they ended up never using his tests in France. Instead, it was the Americans who fell in love with Alfred Benet's test, and they used it to measure the very thing the French psychologists had warned against. They used it to assess intelligence. It completely betrayed the spirit, the philosophy, the principles upon which Benei originally wanted to create the test, completely betrayed him. On his deathbed, he wrote an essay saying the Americans have betrayed me.
这个人有什么能力。甚至没有开始报告这个人有什么能力。那个故事的巨大悲剧是，他们最终在法国从未使用过他的测试。相反，是美国人爱上了阿尔弗雷德·比奈的测试，他们用它来衡量法国心理学家警告过的事情。他们用它来评估智力。它完全背叛了比奈最初想要创建测试的精神、哲学、原则，完全背叛了他。在他临终时，他写了一篇论文说美国人背叛了我。
The psychologist Lewis Turman at Stanford was among those who transformed Bini's test in the United States. Instead of being used as a tool to direct resources to kids who needed help, he turned the test into a tracking tool to identify the gifted. Turman was very, very interested in giftedness and really had this idea in his head that genius is only recruited from the line of high IQ. There's a lot of people involved in these the early days of applying IQ tests. It's really the application part here we're talking about using it to sort people in America that betrayed the original
斯坦福大学的心理学家刘易斯·特曼是美国那些改造比奈测试的人之一。他没有将其用作将资源引导给需要帮助的孩子的工具，而是将测试变成了识别天才的追踪工具。特曼对天才非常非常感兴趣，并且真的在脑海中认为天才只是从高智商的行列中招募的。在应用智商测试的早期阶段，有很多参与者。我们在这里谈论的确实是应用部分，使用它来在美国家庭中对人进行分类，这背叛了最初的
philosophy They made into multiple choice tests and gave gave it out to entire school systems gave it out to in the army gave it out They used it in lots of ways to Send back people coming in from Ellis Island, right? Like you know, you're two feeble minded to come to America. You know, never mind that a lot of these tests had verbal components to it. And you're giving people who English
哲学。他们把它变成了多项选择题，并分发给整个学校系统，分发给军队，分发给它。他们用它来做很多事情，把从埃利斯岛进来的人送回去，对吧？就像你知道，你太弱智了，不能来美国。你知道，别管这些测试中有很多语言成分。而你给那些英语
is not their first language. It's mind-boggling the extent to which this test, which did have some potential for real utility, how much it was abused in the earliest days of use of those tests. Lewis Turman drew on the work of German psychologist William Stern and helped popularize the notion of something called an intelligence quotient, what we now know today as IQ. Mathematically, there's a formula that a lot of people start using in America, which I think
不是母语的人。这个测试在最早使用时被滥用的程度令人难以置信，尽管它确实有一些真正效用的潜力。刘易斯·特曼借鉴了德国心理学家威廉·斯特恩的工作，并帮助普及了所谓的“智商”概念，也就是我们今天所知的智商。在数学上，有一个公式，很多人开始在美国使用，我认为
is indicative of the way they thought about intelligence, right? And to understand the formula, you have to understand the difference between mental age and chronological age. But they're basically saying, you could be 13. That's your chronological age in terms of your biology, in terms of your mental age can be below that or above it. So your mental age, you could be a 13-year-old
这表明了他们思考智力的方式，对吧？要理解这个公式，你必须理解心理年龄和实际年龄之间的区别。但他们基本上是在说，你可能是13岁。那是你的实际年龄，就你的生物学而言，就你的心理年龄而言，可以低于或高于它。所以你的心理年龄，你可能是一个13岁的人
with a mental age of seven and they called you backwards. That was the term that used, your backwards if that's the case. But you're gifted if your mental age far exceeds your chronological age. So, McIntosh obviously was one of the most respected researchers in the field of intelligence, but he was also genuinely open-minded and responsive and curious and not sort of dogmatic. Can you just describe that? You in some ways were coming to him, perhaps, with an agenda that he didn't know, that your agenda was really to pull down the edifice
心理年龄为7岁，他们称你为“落后”。这就是他们使用的术语，如果那样的话，你就是落后的。但如果你的心理年龄远超你的实际年龄，你就是天才。所以，麦金托什显然是智力领域最受尊敬的研究人员之一，但他也是真正思想开放、反应灵敏、好奇且不教条的人。你能描述一下吗？你在某种程度上可能带着他不知道的议程来找他，你的议程实际上是拆除智力
of intelligence and intelligence testing, and maybe he didn't know that you were a saboteur who had just arrived at Cambridge University, but described to me the way he worked and sort of the effect this had on you and the way you started thinking about the questions you were grappling with. Macintosh was a traditional British psychometrician.
和智力测试的大厦，也许他不知道你是一个刚刚到达剑桥大学的破坏者，但向我描述他工作的方式，以及这给你带来的影响，以及你开始思考你正在努力解决的问题的方式。麦金托什是一位传统的英国心理测量学家。
I mean, that's a good traditional IQ as you get on paper and pencil. But his personality and his demeanor and everything about him just signaled a pure, pure love of science. No agenda, no agenda on Nick McIntosh's part. He wrote a textbook, The Science of IQ, which I remember reading, and it almost instantly made me a, I won't say convert, I don't know if that word quite applies, but it almost instantly seduced me into loving the science of IQ intelligence.
我的意思是，那是纸笔上能得到的好传统智商。但他的个性和风度以及关于他的一切都标志着对科学纯粹、纯粹的热爱。没有议程，尼克·麦金托什没有任何议程。他写了一本教科书《智商科学》，我记得读过它，它几乎立刻让我成为一个，我不会说皈依者，我不知道那个词是否完全适用，但它几乎立刻就让我沉迷于爱上智商科学。
And I forgot that I was supposed to be on this vendetta. I forgot. At one point, Nick McIntosh asked a simple question. Assume for a moment that there is no underlying innate ability called intelligence. Some people are good at math, others are good at reading. But if that was the case, he asked, why is it teachers often noticed that the same students who do well at math
我忘记了自己本应带着复仇的心态而来。我忘记了。有一次，尼克·麦金托什问了一个简单的问题。假设有一刻，没有所谓的智力这种潜在的天生能力。有些人擅长数学，另一些人擅长阅读。但如果是那样的话，他问，为什么老师经常注意到那些在数学方面表现出色的学生
also do well at reading? I mean, if you read this book, the science of IQ by Macintosh, it's just so interesting to see all the little nuances of the field, Things like things I just didn't dawn on me could be true. I had all these like ideologies and thoughts that there's no such thing as general intelligence or that IQ doesn't matter in life. You know, and then here I am in reading in this textbook, generally didn't have to
也擅长阅读吗？我的意思是，如果你读过麦金托什（Macintosh）写的《智商科学》（The Science of IQ）这本书，你会发现了解这个领域的所有细微差别非常有趣，有些事情我以前根本没想过可能是真的。我曾经有各种各样的意识形态和想法，认为根本不存在所谓的通用智力，或者智商在生活中并不重要。你知道，然后我就在这里读着这本教科书，其实并不一定非得是这样，
be this way, but it's very curious that someone's score on a nonverbal IQ test could correlate so highly with someone's score on a verbal. And then he would ask questions like, what is it about vocabulary that could be in common in terms of cognitive processes, then rotating an image in the mind? What does vocabulary have in common with cognitive processes like rotating an image in the mind? If verbal skills and spatial skills were just that, skills that could be learned with practice, wasn't it odd that the kids who were good at one
但非常奇怪的是，一个人的非语言智商测试分数竟然能与他的语言测试分数高度相关。然后他会问一些问题，比如，在认知过程方面，词汇量有什么共同之处，然后是在脑海中旋转图像？词汇量与在脑海中旋转图像这样的认知过程有什么共同之处？如果语言技能和空间技能仅仅是可以通过练习习得的技能，那么那些擅长其中一项的孩子，
were often also good at the other? Scott found himself intrigued by questions like this. My curiosity just took over, you know, and I started actually doing really traditional, serious experimental research with him when I got there to Cambridge. There was a second area when Nick McIntar started to sway Scott's pre-existing views about IQ tests.
往往也擅长另一项，这难道不奇怪吗？斯科特发现自己对这类问题很感兴趣。你知道，我的好奇心占据了上风，当我到达剑桥时，我开始真正地与他一起进行非常传统、严肃的实验研究。当尼克·麦金托什（Nick Mackintosh）开始动摇斯科特对智商测试的既有观点时，出现了第二个领域。
Something that I found fascinating when I started to go to Nick McIntar's lectures. He did present data showing the correlation between IQ and lots of outcomes in life. And that was a time I did feel a little triggered based on my childhood. And I found it very, very interesting and almost a moral quandary. He presented like basically the same table I saw when I was 16 and said, f*** that in the library. He presented that in his lecture, University Cambridge showing the different IQ bands and what they tend to do in their life. Like, oh my gosh, this didn't really, this chart again. I kind of like snapped back to my childhood. And I was like, whoa, what do I do? Because this is the science, this is the data.
当我开始去听尼克·麦金托什的讲座时，我发现了一些让我着迷的事情。他确实展示了智商与生活中许多结果之间相关性的数据。在那一刻，基于我的童年经历，我确实感到有点被触动了。我发现这非常、非常有趣，几乎是一个道德困境。他展示的基本上就是我16岁时在图书馆里看到的那张表，当时我说“去他的”。他在剑桥大学的讲座中展示了那张表，显示了不同的智商区间以及人们在生活中倾向于做什么。就像，天哪，怎么又是这张图表。我仿佛回到了童年。我当时想，我该怎么办？因为这就是科学，这就是数据。
Scott's foray into the lion's den of IQ testing hadn't turned out the way he'd expected. When we come back, how Scott responded to his moral quandary. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Early in his career, intelligence researcher Scott Barry Kaufman set out to tear down the edifice of IQ testing. He felt it had greatly limited his own prospects as a young person. But then he found himself convinced by much of the science behind IQ. It left him with a quandary. Should he trust his own experience with IQ tests, or should he trust the data? As he finished
斯科特闯入智商测试的“狮子穴”并没有像他预期的那样发展。稍后回来，我们将探讨斯科特是如何应对他的道德困境的。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain），我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。在他的职业生涯早期，智力研究员斯科特·巴里·考夫曼（Scott Barry Kaufman）着手推翻智商测试的大厦。他觉得这极大地限制了他作为一个年轻人的前景。但后来，他发现自己被智商背后的许多科学所说服。这让他陷入了一个困境。他应该相信自己对智商测试的亲身经历，还是应该相信数据？当他完成
his undergraduate studies and went on to get a PhD in cognitive psychology, Scott came to feel that the real question was not whether the science of IQ was wrong, but whether it was incomplete. One thing that IQ tests had not looked at was how much a person cared about what they were doing. When you go take an IQ test, it tends to be divorced entirely from the context of your own life. That's by design. They want to see how good a you at abstract reasoning, and that's thought to be the height of your own life. That's by design. They want to see how good a you at abstract reasoning.
他的本科学习并继续攻读认知心理学博士学位时，斯科特开始觉得真正的问题不在于智商科学是否错误，而在于它是否不完整。智商测试没有考虑的一件事是，一个人对自己所做的事情有多在意。当你去参加智商测试时，它往往与你生活的背景完全脱节。这是刻意设计的。他们想看看你在抽象推理方面有多出色，这被认为是智力的巅峰。这是刻意设计的。他们想看看你在抽象推理方面有多出色。
And that's thought to be the height of intelligence. However, so much of life is not de-contextualized from our life. In fact, most of our life, we are excited about certain things. We are our attentional system is directed towards it. This engagement aspect is absolutely essential to our understanding of someone's potential. The more we engage in something we learn, and the more that we learn something,
这被认为是智力的巅峰。然而，生活中的大部分内容并非与我们的生活脱节。事实上，在我们生活的大部分时间里，我们对某些事物感到兴奋。我们的注意力系统指向它。这种参与感对于我们理解一个人的潜力绝对至关重要。我们参与学习的东西越多，我们学到的东西就越多，
the more it makes us want to engage in something, because once we start becoming good at something, then we start to invest more of our time and energy into it. So it's a very strong dynamic cycle. Teachers, managers, and coaches can testify to Scots Insight. Talent matters, but sometimes passion and drive matter more. Along with deep engagement, creativity is another driver of performance that is overlooked by IQ tests.
它就越让我们想要参与其中，因为一旦我们开始擅长某事，我们就会开始投入更多的时间和精力。所以这是一个非常强大的动态循环。教师、经理和教练可以证明斯科特的见解。天赋固然重要，但有时热情和动力更重要。除了深度参与之外，创造力是另一个被智商测试所忽视的绩效驱动因素。
In fact, researchers have found that they can be an inverse relationship between intelligence and creativity. When you look at the neuroscience of creativity, those who have the most imaginative sort of ideas are the kind of brains that show reduction of grave volume in what's called the prefrontal cortex. So sometimes you actually find that that some of the brains that look the least intelligent are actually the most creative. That's the point I'm trying to make here. So it depends a lot on your ability sometimes put aside all the prior expertise you have. Maybe even put aside your critical thinking facilities.
事实上，研究人员发现智力与创造力之间可能存在反比关系。当你观察创造力的神经科学时，那些拥有最具想象力想法的人，其大脑在所谓的“前额叶皮层”中显示出灰质体积的减少。所以有时你实际上会发现，一些看起来最不聪明的大脑实际上是最具创造力的。这就是我试图表达的观点。所以这在很大程度上取决于你有时放下所有先前专业知识的能力。甚至可能放下你的批判性思维能力。
And be able to really have more associative processes. I like to say it's really important to be really open minded, but not so open minded that your brain falls out. So that's why I think intelligence is important. I'm not saying intelligence isn't important. But it depends on the thing that you're creating. I actually published a paper showing the distinction between the arts and the sciences and it's predicted of IQ, in the extent to which IQ predicts these things. And you find IQ had a zero correlation with artistic creative achievement in life.
并且能够真正拥有更多的联想过程。我喜欢说，保持开放的心态非常重要，但不要开放到让你的大脑掉出来。这就是为什么我认为智力很重要。我并不是说智力不重要。但这取决于你正在创造的东西。我实际上发表了一篇论文，展示了艺术与科学之间的区别，以及智商在多大程度上预测这些事情。你发现智商与生活中的艺术创造力成就之间存在零相关性。
And why do you think it is that in artistic fields you're not seeing a connection between IQ and outcomes. What do you think is happening there if you're a painter or a poet or a musician? One important cognitive process that's associated with arts is what's called latent inhibition and it's particularly reduced in inhibition. So usually we tend to see the world and tag things as relevant or irrelevant to a problem we're working on based on our prior expectations. But people in the arts are really good at constantly seeing things with fresh eyes. They're constantly good at putting aside their prior preconceptions and trying to find meaning in the here and now.
你认为为什么在艺术领域你没有看到智商与结果之间的联系？如果你是一名画家、诗人或音乐家，你认为那里发生了什么？与艺术相关的一个重要认知过程被称为“潜在抑制”，特别是抑制的减少。所以通常我们倾向于根据我们先前的期望来看待世界，并将事物标记为与我们正在处理的问题相关或不相关。但艺术领域的人非常擅长不断地以全新的眼光看待事物。他们非常擅长不断地放下先前的成见，并试图在此时此地寻找意义。
And we've published papers and there are other papers showing that people who tend to have a reduced lean inhibition, reduced tend to score higher in the arts creative achievement domain. Also, it's correlated with openness to experience as well. The personality trait openness to experience, openness to aesthetics, openness to beauty, and also emotions. Being able to tap into the rich, rich tapestry of your emotions and not view some of your emotions as awful limits, like saying you always have to be happy all the time, but actually saying, you know, I'm actually going to take this
我们已经发表了论文，还有其他论文表明，那些倾向于潜在抑制减少的人，在艺术创造力成就领域往往得分更高。此外，它也与“对经验的开放性”相关。人格特质中的对经验的开放性、对美学的开放性、对美的开放性，以及情感。能够挖掘你丰富的情感宝库，而不是将你的一些情绪视为可怕的限制，比如认为你必须一直保持快乐，而是实际上说，你知道，我实际上要接受我正在经历的
depression, I'm going through and use that as fodder for creativity. You've also said that IQ tests failed to capture the full range of human potential in that they focus on the explicit, the conscious, the controlled forms of thinking. What is this leave-out Scott? Absolutely. Well, one specific thing I did study in my dissertation is this idea called implicit learning, which is our ability to learn the probabilistic rule structure of the world automatically and implicitly without our level of awareness. This is deep implications. So I mean
抑郁，并将其用作创造力的素材。你还说过，智商测试未能捕捉到人类潜力的全部范围，因为它们专注于显性的、有意识的、受控的思维形式。这留下了什么空白，斯科特？绝对是。嗯，我在论文中研究的一件具体事情是这个叫做“内隐学习”的概念，这是我们自动且内隐地学习世界概率规则结构的能力，而无需我们的意识水平参与。这有深远的影响。所以我的意思是
so you talk about the theme of your show right here. We're getting to this is very very congruent. I mean think about what is required to develop social intelligence. Sometimes when people smile, they mean this. Sometimes they don't. Sometimes when people's eyes are like this sometimes they don't. You know, the world is messy. And I, from a cognitive scientist lens, I developed tasks to measure differences in people's ability to learn about the probabilistic structure of something.
所以你谈到了你节目的主题。我们正在谈论的内容非常一致。我的意思是，想想发展社会智力需要什么。有时当人们微笑时，他们是这个意思。有时他们不是。有时当人们的眼睛是这样时，有时他们不是。你知道，世界是混乱的。而且，从认知科学家的角度来看，我开发了一些任务来衡量人们学习某种事物的概率结构的能力差异。
And we have found that's virtually uncorrelated, wholly uncorrelated with IQ. The people that can go into an IQ testing, one of our sessions, be like, A, C, B, D, and get like, strongly off the charts IQ, oftentimes the ones that are not learning implicitly. Solving puzzles involves logic and analysis, but logic cannot help you read someone's expression in a crowded room. That requires cognitive skills that are often learned unconsciously. Scott is not merely saying that the cognitive ability that IQ tests measure is different
我们发现这与智商几乎不相关，完全不相关。那些可以参加智商测试，参加我们的一场会议，得到A、C、B、D，并获得超高智商的人，往往不是那些进行内隐学习的人。解决谜题涉及逻辑和分析，但逻辑无法帮助你在拥挤的房间里读懂某人的表情。这需要通常在无意识中习得的认知技能。斯科特不仅仅是在说智商测试所测量的认知能力是不同的
than the abilities that allow us to apprehend unwritten patterns and relationships in the real world. He's saying that sometimes these different cognitive abilities might come in the expense of each other. It's like a sea-sol, sometimes the thing on one side causing you challenges brings you up in another way. He sees this especially among so-called two e-kits. Two e stands for twice exceptional where you have a profound, extraordinary difficulty or challenge in
与那些让我们能够理解现实世界中不成文的模式和关系的技能相比。他是在说，有时这些不同的认知能力可能会以牺牲彼此为代价。这就像一个跷跷板，有时跷跷板一端给你带来挑战的事情，在另一方面却让你提升了。他特别在所谓的“双重特殊”（2e）孩子身上看到了这一点。2e代表“双重特殊”，即你在生活中有着深刻、非凡的困难或挑战，
your life, and you also have a profound gift or talent or ability. But there are people that really do have profound difficulties and profound gifts and towns in one body. And in some ways, it complicates the notion of how we think about people, right? We think about smart people as always being smart, dull people always being dull. And what you're doing partly with sort of this two-way label is basically saying, no, people are more complicated than that.
同时你也有深刻的天赋、才能或能力。但确实有人在同一个身体里既有深刻的困难，又有深刻的天赋和才能。在某种程度上，这使我们思考人的概念变得复杂，对吧？我们认为聪明人总是聪明的，迟钝的人总是迟钝的。而你通过这种“双重特殊”标签所做的事情，基本上是在说，不，人比那复杂得多。
Absolutely. I saw that just going only back to the sixth grade Scott who heard the announcement on the, you know, the speaker, gifted kids go to their room. I sensed in my gut there's something much more complicated about humans than the way that we're dividing and sorting people here. And I still believe it. And I believe it in so many ways, you know, like hidden ways that we don't explicitly acknowledge in our society, old systems, especially in an education system, but you also see it in organizations and hiring practices. It goes deep this stuff.
绝对是。我看到这一点，仅仅回到六年级，斯科特听到了扬声器里的广播，天才儿童去他们的房间。我直觉地感觉到，人类比我们在这里划分和分类人的方式要复杂得多。我仍然相信这一点。而且我以许多方式相信它，你知道，比如在我们社会中没有明确承认的隐藏方式，旧的系统，特别是在教育系统中，但你在组织和招聘实践中也能看到它。这东西很深。
A lot of these assumptions we have about human potential that are really outdated and just wrong. So the story that has stuck with me, I think, through this whole episode is the one that you told me about the school psychologist who looked at your IQ test and showed you where you fell on the belt curve of intelligence and started with a gifted and moved the pencil over and over and over to the left and then to the left and then more to the left. That moment was really crushing for you in all kinds of ways. But some years ago you had an extraordinary experience.
我们对人类潜力的许多假设确实已经过时且完全错误。所以，我想在整个节目中一直萦绕在我心头的故事，就是你告诉我的那个学校心理学家的故事，他看了你的智商测试，向你展示了你在智力钟形曲线上的位置，从天才开始，一遍又一遍地把铅笔向左移动，然后向左，然后向左。那一刻对你来说在各方面都是毁灭性的。但几年前你经历了一次非凡的体验。
You were walking in a park in Philadelphia and you came by an elderly man sitting on a park bench. Set the scene for me and tell me that story, Scott. I was really happy. I was pumped. I just had a nice weightlifting session and I'm running and I crossed a man on a bench and I feel something in my gut like dread. Like why am I feeling dread? I don't know. I look back at the person and then it hits me. That's the school psychologist
你在费城的一个公园里散步，经过一位坐在公园长椅上的老人。为我设定场景，告诉我那个故事，斯科特。我当时真的很开心。我充满了活力。我刚做完一次很棒的举重训练，我正在跑步，我经过一个坐在长椅上的人，我直觉地感觉到一种恐惧。就像我为什么会感到恐惧？我不知道。我回头看那个人，然后我突然明白了。那是高中时的学校心理学家，
from high school who drew the bell curve on the napkin and basically Inspired me to go into this field not in the way that he would have ever thought but Like that's him. He's older, but I recognize him and It did create a bit of a dilemma in me, which is like what do I do? I approach him. Do I say hi? Do I, what, do I sock him in the face? Ha, ha, ha, ha, what do I do? And with a lot of trepidation and my heart beating very fast, I approached him on the park bench and I said,
他在餐巾纸上画了钟形曲线，基本上激励了我进入这个领域，虽然不是他所想的那种方式，但那就是他。他老了，但我认出了他。这确实在我心中制造了一个小小的困境，就是我该怎么办？我接近他吗？我打招呼吗？我该怎么办，我该揍他一拳吗？哈哈哈哈，我该怎么办？带着很多不安和剧烈的心跳，我走近公园长椅上的他，我说，
hey, do you mind if I, if I just sit next to you for a second, I will tell you something. And he's like, sure no problem, no problem. And I sat down and I said, Hey, I was a student of yours and you changed my life. And he said, Oh, yeah, by in a sort of screw, you sort of way probably. And you said that. And I laughed. and I said, well, you know, you just, you did. I did, you know, I'm a psychologist now. And I didn't feel the need to yell at him or tell him the whole story.
嘿，你介意我坐在你旁边一会儿吗？我会告诉你一些事情。他说，当然没问题，没问题。我坐下来，我说，嘿，我曾经是你的学生，你改变了我的人生。他说，哦，是吗，用一种大概是“去你的”那种语气。你说了那个。我笑了，我说，嗯，你知道，你确实改变了。我现在是一名心理学家了。我没有觉得需要对他大喊大叫或告诉他整个故事。
But he said something very interesting to me when I told him I'm a psychologist now. He said, oh, he's like, well, that's interesting. I'm actually tutoring a kid right now who really low IQ, really low IQ is really not the sharpest tool in the shed. My blood boiled a bit and I, I called myself down. I just said, maybe you can just keep looking deeper at beyond the IQ and to maybe think about him in a bit of a broader way and where you
但他告诉我现在是一名心理学家时，他说了一些非常有趣的话。他说，哦，他说，嗯，那很有趣。我实际上正在辅导一个孩子，智商真的很低，智商真的很低，真的不是最聪明的人。我的血有点沸腾，我让自己冷静下来。我只是说，也许你可以试着更深入地看待智商之外的东西，也许可以以更广阔的方式思考他，以及你在哪里
look at the totality of him, not a particular slice of him when you're making that kind of judgment call. And he agreed. I mean, he agreed to his credit. He's like, that's a good point. And I just kind of realized in that moment, like, you know what, like he's not evil, he's human. He was probably doing the best that he could at the time in what he knew and how he was
看待他的整体，而不是在做出那种判断时只看他的一部分。他同意了。我的意思是，值得称赞的是，他同意了。他说，那是个好观点。我当时就意识到，你知道吗，他不是邪恶的，他是人类。他当时可能是在他所知和受训方式的范围内尽了最大的努力，
trained. And even now, he was doing the best he can to try to help this kid. And the best I could do is not yell at him or tell him my story, but to just tell him about the field of Twice exceptional and to tell him about, well maybe here's some resources. So I offered him some resources to help this kid based on the research. I've done. I was someone told him that and when I was in 11th grade, maybe he would have treated me differently. But then again, if he treated me differently, maybe I wouldn't have been in the position to ever
即使是现在，他也在尽力帮助这个孩子。我能做的最好的事情不是对他大喊大叫或告诉他我的故事，而是告诉他关于“双重特殊”的领域，并告诉他，也许这里有一些资源。所以我根据我所做的研究，提供了一些资源来帮助这个孩子。如果有人在11年级时告诉他这些，也许他会以不同的方式对待我。但话说回来，如果他以不同的方式对待我，也许我就不会处于那个位置，
even be that park bench to tell him that. So it's all very weird. I don't know, wife sometimes, you just gotta go with it. Psychologist Scott Barry Kaufman studies the science of human potential. He is the author of Ungifted, Intelligence Redefined, and Transcend, the new science of self-actualization. Scott, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, this is wonderful. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura
甚至在那张公园长椅上告诉他这些。所以这一切都很奇怪。我不知道，生活有时，你只需要顺其自然。心理学家斯科特·巴里·考夫曼研究人类潜力的科学。他是《不被定义：重新定义智力》（Ungifted: Intelligence Redefined）和《超越：自我实现的科学》（Transcend: The New Science of Self-Actualization）的作者。斯科特，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢，这太棒了。《隐藏的大脑》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲-保罗（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉
Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung heroes today are Jay and Jessica Shear. Jay is a novelist and runs a nonprofit production company called the Reclimation Society. Jessica is an editor of nonfiction and fiction books. We recently had some questions about the publishing industry, and Jay and Jessica graciously made time to chat and share their insights.
夸雷尔（Quarelle）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们今天的无名英雄是杰伊（Jay）和杰西卡·希尔（Jessica Shear）。杰伊是一位小说家，经营着一家名为“回收协会”（Reclimation Society）的非营利性制作公司。杰西卡是非虚构和虚构书籍的编辑。我们最近有一些关于出版业的问题，杰伊和杰西卡慷慨地抽出时间聊天并分享了他们的见解。
Thank you Jay and Jessica. If you enjoy Hidden Brain and have found the ideas we explored to be useful in your own life, please consider supporting our work. You can do so at support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantan. See you soon. Ben Şanker Vedatım. Siyussun. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢杰伊和杰西卡。如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》，并发现我们探索的想法对你自己的生活有用，请考虑支持我们的工作。你可以在 support.hiddenbrain.org 上这样做。再说一遍，那是 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。